hey everybody is Jessie and we're going
to do some geolocation stuff today so
the brought there's the geolocation API
for the browser where I'm sure you've
seen this before a web site will ask you
know can we get your location or
something like that and if you allow
them to get your location then usually
they use that to tell you either you
know what's the weather near you or what
events are near you or maybe give you
get you directions to somewhere so in
this case we want to get the location of
the user and then compare it to the
location of our events and then order
our events from those that are closest
to those that are farthest away before I
get started I just want to let you know
that about 12 minutes ago the power went
out here so if everything just gets cut
off it's the power probably went out
again so it's their big thunderstorms
happening right now so hopefully it
won't happen again but if it does I'll
try to get restarted and get back on as
soon as I can
I've never had a stream cut out in the
middle so I'm not even sure if I can
join the same stream again or not I'm
thinking yes because I wouldn't have
actually clicked the button to stop the
stream it'll just say like I've lost
connection so as long as you get the
computer up and running and start OBS
again to start streaming should be good
to go so also I want to acknowledge the
contributions that you all have made so
a lot of people contribute in the live
chat and are very helpful but then also
I've had some people contribute directly
to the repository for the site we've
been working on so so Vinay
and Danny and Fabian or I thought about
the other day since you're from France
it's probably not pronounced Fabian so
Fabien I'm not sure let me know if
you're watching so anyway thanks so much
for these contributions and feel free to
contribute I started putting some issues
in in the repo so I'm going to make try
to remember to put the issues in here
and maybe if if you've never contributed
to a repository before some of these are
going to be pretty easy some more
in-depth but you know maybe it'll get
you some practice in how to contribute
and you know certainly nobody feel
obligated to contribute this is
definitely the project is completely my
responsibility but I know it's some
sometimes it's intimidating to try to
submit pull requests to projects so this
might be a nice like small project to
get just to get a feel for for how you
do it
and if you need any help let me know and
I could try to walk you through it
and if you submit a pull request and
it's not exactly what I need no big deal
I'll just let you know what needs
changed and you make the changes and
submit it again I'm not going to be
upset if you submit a bunch of pull
requests I'm happy for the assistants so
anyway let's let's get started let me
move this out of here because we don't
need it right now so here's the steps I
was just kind of thinking in the last
few minutes before I started this video
what we need to do we need to add let me
know if this is too small I think this
is the same font size we had yesterday I
don't think I mess with it so if it was
okay yesterday should still be good we
need to add a map field to the nearby
event custom post type
that's going to show up in WordPress so
let me let me show you this here I
actually already added it but I didn't
add in an API key and I need to so
that's why this isn't working right now
so that step is partially finished once
that's in place we'll fill out some data
in there so we have something coming in
through the API and then we need to
prompt the user for their location
that's the part we'll use the
geolocation API which I had open
somewhere but after I had to restart my
computer from the the power outage all
my windows are in different places so
I'll try to find it it might actually be
faster to just search for it again
because I have so many windows open
after that we need to compare the user's
location to the event location so this
should be working we'll have the
latitude and longitude for both of these
then we're going to show the events
we're going to put the closest events
that are closest to the user first and
then go from there to where those are
farthest away the last one I think is
just wishful thinking and that's in the
stream one time which really ever
happens but I'm going to try so I was in
a little bit earlier than normal this
morning so I really don't want to be
here super late and I also work through
my lunch break so I can definitely get
out of here I could probably leave now
and be fine but I want to do the stream
so I'm going to check the the live chat
and just say hello to everybody before
we get started everyone
azar says hello from mars hi sam says i
enjoy these are becoming a more daily
thing yeah it's it's intended to be a
daily thing at least Monday through
Friday but I had some there were some
times when I was I couldn't stream
because either I was sick or
occasionally the stream time changes
because I have meetings but basically
yet it's it should be pretty much every
day if I can
hey no D no DS back how's it going says
second time on the streams and ODS does
Jessie like to html/css j/s beginner
kind of stuff yes I do like to do that
so if you're more like at the beginner
level when you're looking at this like
this is over my head we're at the end of
a project so at the beginning of this
project if you go back to watch some of
the first recordings it'll be way more
beginner level now we're to the end so
you know we've already taken a lot of
those little steps and now we have
something a lot more complex so it's
hard to jump in at this point although
I'm still going to try to explain things
as best I can so hopefully no matter
what level you're at you'll still get
something out of it as soon as I'm done
with this project I'll jump into another
project and that'll be like starting all
over again so I always try to do
something new or something better a try
a new tool or something so each project
will be a little bit different but its
end up it's going to be like a cycle of
you know going back to the basics of
setting up a site and then building on
that so if it's if it's a little bit
over your head right now don't worry you
know give it a week or so I'll be done
with this site and then you know we'll
be right back to some basic stuff I am
also going to put some videos on my
personal channel that are going to be
more like really basic level tutorial
video
and I have I have some outlines and some
notes ready for those it's just a matter
of finding a little bit of time where
it's quiet enough at my house or some
time at work to just do those videos
okay all right great Rohan says font
size is good and also that's Google Maps
API yes so I'm going to be using the
Google Maps API at the very least within
WordPress here to pull up a Google map
and basically what I want so you can see
this right now the content editor comes
in here fills out the title of the event
the date and then displayed date which
if you're not sure why I have two
different dates here check out
yesterday's episode and I explained why
I needed the date in two different
formats here you know and they fill out
this basic info but now in addition to
the location and this is how it will
actually display I also wanted to put
the location here if they search and
type in the location here then it should
on the API and it'll come out with with
some data probably multiple fields but
one of those fields will contain the
latitude and longitude and that's what I
need so that's that's what I'm going to
use the Google Maps API here and then
we'll see for this step
compare the user location to event
location I may need to use some sort of
API so I don't really know what the best
API is I I did a little bit of research
beforehand so if you all have experience
with this let me know what you think I'm
also thinking a really kind of fast way
to do this potentially could be to just
do some comparisons with just the raw
latitude and longitude
potentially it might be possible to just
do some basic math comparing the
latitude/longitude of the event to the
user location and then be able to give a
rough kind of estimate of distance from
the user so this you know these are
going to be pinpoint locations they're
just going to be the general location of
a city so it doesn't need to be like
super exact so if you have any ideas for
that as well let me know what you know
we'll get into that more when we get to
this step though and then see what the
best way to do this would be if you're
just joining for the first time I will
say these aren't tutorials this is me
just doing my daily work so that's why
I'm saying things like I don't really
know what we're going to do let's try it
because that's that's my work I know I
want to do this this part of the website
is arguably going to be the most useful
part of the site to our users and I
think this feature in particular will be
the most useful feature of this part of
the site this nearby events part so so I
know I want it I know how I want it to
work and I just need to figure out how
to make it work with all of you helping
all right let's see just had a bunch of
stuff in the live chat so I just want to
check it out very quickly and this will
give you a few minutes to to think about
these these steps and these questions
Philip says I'm a self-taught coder and
I just recently stumbled on your site
best self learning resource ever Wow
that's I'm glad you think that awesome
and thanks thanks for saying that I love
comments like that it keeps me going and
keeps me thinking that this is a
worthwhile thing to do so I really
appreciate that
why is m23 says hi I'm new here
hey welcome welcome to the channel ask
any questions if you confused about
what's going on the people in the live
chat are super helpful and knowledgeable
and I also try to get to all the
questions as well sometimes I don't get
to them till the end of the stream if
you can't stick around to the at end of
the stream just direct message me on
Twitter or something and I can answer
your question later on so but uh welcome
s/m says how would you recommend
learning react the free code camp course
doesn't have much on it yet yeah that's
true it doesn't have much on it yet I
would say like tutorial videos are nice
the react documentation itself like the
basic react website has a pretty good
kind of walkthrough for react and I
think I think code Academy um has a
react course now for free I like vaguely
remember taking that course a while back
when it first came out so that's those
are my that's my best advice and check
out some of the earlier videos when we
just started this project it'll maybe
get you a good idea of how to like get
started and then you can mess around
with it and that's kind of the best way
really is you know use something to jump
starter projects and then so you can
actually start changing things and see
what happens
so and I'm sure some of you all that are
watching probably have some great
resources too so you know please put
that in the latch at as well or in the
comments this video
Kolak asks this is react native right
now it's just regular react not react
native yet I'd love to do something with
react native at some point if I can I
don't have any projects coming up at my
job that will need react native anytime
soon so it might have to be a side
project Yakko lac says so what's the
scope of this project run react on
WordPress yeah basically WordPress is
the content management and it exists on
a separate server and then we use the
WordPress API to pull in all the content
into a react site that has server-side
rendering and it runs on a bit totally
different server running node and and
react
we actually have nginx running as well
yeah rhoann is actually we do a browser
location or IP based we're going to do
the browser location Sam says Google
Maps has a shortest path map so yeah
maybe that might be the best thing best
thing to do alright I think that's it
for I really at the beginning I want to
see if there's anybody new that has any
questions to kind of get them out I
don't want them to leave and you know
think they're being inordinately so so
I'm going to get check out so Cole AK
asks why use a separate react site for
pulling content from WordPress if you
can stick around to the towards the end
I will answer that in depth for now I'm
sure a few of the people in the live
chat that have heard me say this a
couple of times can can fill you in
so if somebody wants to take that on and
fill them in really quick I'll get
started but I'll definitely answer you
at the end given more full explanation
and then if you get a chance to watch
some of the past videos I do explain it
kind of as I'm going what I'm doing but
let's let's get started so first things
first let's get this thing working so we
need to get an API key for Google Google
Maps so let me look up I like I said
that the power went out and now my
windows are in the wrong places so I had
a lot of this documentation ready and I
don't know where it is maybe I did just
close it out but so let's try this
[Music]
they see Matthew it there we go all
right so I'm just gonna I'm using the
plug-in advanced custom fields and that
just helps me make these custom fields a
lot faster than I would be able to if I
was doing it in like a custom plugin
with PHP just because I'm not great with
PHP so if you're not awesome at PHP I
recommend using something like this so
let's see here we go
so API key all right looks like I will
have to edit some PHP so oh well I guess
so I guess I can't get around it here so
unexpectedly we'll be doing a little PHP
today a little WordPress PHP this
doesn't look too difficult I'm saying
put this in the functions the PHP file I
kind of don't want to put in functions
about PHP we do already have our custom
plugin I hate to throw it in with that
but it's somewhat fits in there because
that plugin is creating custom post
types and this is just enabling a field
for one of those custom post types that
we're already creating so it it may make
sense to put that in there I just always
hate to edit functions about PHP
directly especially since we're not
really using any of the functions for
the themes right now since we're just
using the API so yeah we'll try to put
this in our plug-in that we we edited on
maybe sometime last week we're editing
that so anyway let's get the API key
first and get a key I kind of think that
I already have gotten the key before new
projects
see I create in a wiki I
all right awesome all right so yeah
definitely you can all see this API key
right now so don't go crazy with it um
and this is probably a great idea to
restrict its usage so let's do that as
well since I'm putting it on YouTube and
we want it to only come from let me
think this will probably be coming from
the WordPress install so this will be
it is calm I'm not exactly sure where
the rest of it will be so I'm going to
say that hopefully I did that right and
it will work if we try to use this API
key and it doesn't work that maybe I'll
come back here and take out that
restriction because it's possible I
messed that up and that will mess up us
try to use the the API so now let's go
back and see we need to put this in here
I have let's throw that API key in right
here so I don't lose it in case I
accidentally copy something else and let
me grab
so I still if you remember the last time
we were editing this plug-in this PHP
plug-in I I never I didn't get FTP
working so it was supposed to be set up
so that I could use SSH or FTP to get
into that server I did instead of the
server but I'm not sure exactly what
happened but I couldn't get in so I
ended up just doing this which whoops
I'm gonna have to make this bigger so
I'll end up going to the plugins and
where's my not going to edit and just
copy and pasting this which I know this
is this like makes me sad to do this but
at this point especially since we're
streaming this will be way faster than
trying to figure out why I can't get
into the server a more sensible way so
I'm just going to put this over here
and I'm going to grab this
and put this let's see I want to make
sure I put it it looks like I can just
put it at the very bottom but still
inside this PHP yeah so this function I
just want to make sure I'm not putting
it inside of another function and
messing things up okay this should work
also another reason why this makes me
really sad to do it like this is this is
a live site right now and if I mess this
up the site will go down temporarily
there is some caching involved so
there's a decent chance that if it's
only down for a few seconds no one will
notice what I put that API key oh right
here and after I do this and see if it
works I'm going to check check back in
with the live chat as well so if you're
feeling ignored you won't be ignored for
a long that looks like the only thing I
had to I had to change so I'm going to
as much as much as it hurts me to do
this I'm going to copy and paste back in
alright so we have this down here let's
update the file I'm a little
apprehensive because if you've ever
worked with word pressing if you know if
you make an error in one of these
occasionally what will happen is you'll
get this white screen with some text on
it I think it's the white screen or
greyish maybe and you're locked out and
the only way to get back in is you
actually have to get to the files so
since I can't do that I really hope that
um the person who set up the server is
still here at work so that I can run in
real quick and have him do it so let's
give it a shot just I'm saying like you
should probably never do it like this
this is not the right way
to do it alright awesome so it works it
works also keep your WordPress up to
date I don't have it up I'm like one
version behind right now and I don't
want to update until I back up my my
database so I didn't have time to do
that yet so I'm going to back up the
database and then I'm going to update it
might be cool for me to back up the
database like on a video just to show
you how to manually back it up I will do
it live
probably but maybe if I do that like at
some point soon maybe I'll record it I
don't let me know if you're interested
in anything like that okay so we need to
go back to events and we're in this one
let's go back in here and see yes
alright so that's definitely better than
the big error page and let's see where
is this at Marietta hey that's not that
far from where I'm at Marietta Ohio
awesome
okay so Marietta Ohio and let's update
that I'm actually really interested to
see what comes out in the API from this
because I haven't seen it yet so I'm
gonna bring in this I was actually I was
trying to get something to work and I'm
just breathing I'm just going to tell
you in case you have any ideas so I
couldn't get it to work so I have this
plugin called malt it's multiple post
type for WordPress API so you're
supposed to be able to just let me see
if I using this in there we go so you're
supposed to be able to just type in
multiple post type and then you can
access different post types like this
which it does it works like this so I
can actually get all my pages and all my
posts just like this but if I want to
use some parameters here to maybe filter
this I can't get it to work
basically it will filter everything the
same way I can't get it to filter just
one so like let's say if I want one
particular page
and I searched forward by the slug for
that page I won't get any posts because
it'll actually be searching for posts
with that same slug and it didn't matter
where I put that filter in here or what
order I did it I still got the same
result so I'm wondering if this plug-in
in fact just can't do that
maybe it wasn't designed to do that if
that's the case then I'm in a bit of
trouble because I was relying on this to
be able to load multiple different post
types on one page which I'm going to
need to do so let me know if you have
any ideas with that another alternative
that I didn't want to do because it
would result multiple API calls but if
it's the only way to do it
then I'm fine with it would be to figure
out here and basically and get initial
props I'd like to be able to make
multiple API calls in here so I if you
I've tried to make most babyi calls in
here it's only ever resulted in an error
for me but I there's got to be some way
to do it right I mean if we can make one
API call then we can make two right and
I'm just missing some how how to do this
so so think about that if you have a
minute and if you have any thoughts let
me know I'm going to give it a shot
obviously and try to work through it but
if you all have any input that may help
me to work through it a lot faster and I
would appreciate that alright so let's
go back here to what we were going to do
and I want to see what kind of data I'm
getting here
so was this nearby nearby event and I've
already searched that at some point so
there we go that's the one I wanted so
let's go down here to if you've never
seen this before this is uh this is JSON
so this with JSON formatted data
like and this and protect normally
you'll see this actually but I have a
chrome plug-in that makes it look like
this much easier to read but the
wordpress api formats everything like
this and what I want to do normally I
edit I don't get all this extra stuff
that I don't need
but I'm looking okay so the field that I
want would be location underscore map
and really what I'm most interested in
is this latitude and longitude awesome
so we have that there we know how to get
it so let's go back to our steps to see
where we're at so add Matt field good
that's done so we completed this first
one and so let me
all right that will be completed China
thing I was trying to think of like what
could I what symbol could I use that
would indicate completed and I can
really find anything so I know there's
some way to do like a check mark or
something but it's not really a check
mark but I think it's like a math symbol
boat anyway now let's let's go to this
this part so since I I kind of lost the
documentation that I was trying to use
let's look it up again and geolocation
API let me make this bigger so you can
see and yep that's what I was looking
for so using geolocation oh and I said I
was going to check the latch and I
forgot so let me check it again got a
lot of activity going on here I'm gonna
scroll through real quick
okay so I'm I'm right now I'm just kind
of scrolling through for any questions
that are really relevant right now so if
I skip your comment I've seen it I'm
going to come back to it towards the end
of the stream so I'm not I'm seeing them
and I would do definitely intend to get
to them
um
okay rowan says this is pretty relevant
changing the API key and using an
environment variable to store it after
the video might be a good idea so yeah
actually maybe I should change the API
key I don't think I'll need to use an
environment variable because it's not
actually going to go in any of the code
if you remember we well we put it in the
WordPress plug-in that is not actually
in the github repo or anything like that
that plug-in only exists on that
WordPress server and is not really
publicly accessible as far as right now
so let me know if I'm wrong about that
but it should be just enough to change
the API key if I'm not mistaken but that
I mean that's that's good advice
I don't know maybe somebody try to use
that same API key I'll put it up on the
screen somebody try to use my API key
and see if it works for you I don't mean
to order anybody around just if you feel
like it please try to use my API key I
feel like I'm being a little bit bossy
today I don't know I got very little
sleep last night my kids were awake
several of my children were awake
multiple times last night and then I had
meetings all morning so it's just kind
of feeling a little a little little
weird a little tired
okay Amelia says uh I was kind of lost
but I'm seeing that nearby events is
already a plugin for WordPress right
Emilio
yeah I made this plug-in so here you can
see the plugin it's hard to tell because
it's I haven't saved it as a PHP file
locally so it's it doesn't have the
syntax highlighting but basically you
can kind of see here like I'm
registering a post site this is the
resource post site
so I'm registering this post site here
and giving it olden how I like one of
the names to display saying I wanted to
show up in the REST API
and then I'm doing that for a bunch of
them so all these different post types
and then somewhere at the bottom here I
actually yeah create create new type so
so yeah so I just made this plugin just
to add all these post types and down
here I have just some of the code for
custom techsan and these it's all
commented out right now because I don't
have any taxonomy yet I may not need
them so hopefully that clears things up
for you
whoa Rowland says you can force syntax
highlighting by changing it at the
bottom right corner let me check out the
bottom right corner I actually never
mess with any of this stuff in the
bottom right corner what row on you you
are my favorite person of the day unless
somebody else unless somebody else comes
up with something amazing Rohan
definitely wins a favorite person word
for today that is us you don't know how
many times I've I've had a file I didn't
really want to save it locally I just
needed to edit it really quick and and I
have actually saved it with a file
extension at the end just to get the
syntax highlighting and so my my file
structure of my computer is filled with
this these files that we'll never use
again and usually multiple versions of
these files so that's awesome if that's
like really obvious I mean then then I'm
a noob and I'm fine with that I'm really
excited about that all right awesome so
does that mean I could do it with this
too and make this markdown if I wanted
to
and could I then use so I marked down
preview will this work oh no did it open
a third pane Oh awesome
so that does work that's so cool this
also is a problem too off like I just I
don't want to actually save this file I
don't need to but I did want it to
actually show up and be able to use
markdown and now I can although I
definitely don't want it to be in this
third pane here I want this to go away
and I don't need this anymore so this to
go was well let me just move it over
because if I am going to change that API
key sometime soon I'll just leave this
should leave it no I don't really need
it it won't be hard for me to just put
the API key directly into the WordPress
editor even though it's like there's no
syntax highlighting it's kind of hard to
deal with but all right great let me get
back to that's so cool um let's let's
get back to the project
Sam says too bad you guys aren't using
them yeah we've talked about them before
on this stream and basically my opinion
on vim is I'm super jealous of everyone
that knows how to use them and when I
see somebody use it it's like I don't
know it's like a when you're a little
kid you see like the older kids and they
look really cool that's like my view on
people that use vim so it just looks
really cool when they're using it and I
want to be like that one day when I grow
up I want to use them
all right so let's get to geolocation
API is publisher navigator geolocation
object I'm sure this is just like
riveting to watch me go through
documentation so sorry about that
but I do want this to be an accurate
representation of my daily work and a
lot of my daily work is meant going
through documentation okay let's just
grab this really quick and see what we
can do with it
let me just turn this in here because I
want to change this to a console log and
yeah that looks good let's love that
let's throw this in here um where we at
I said I could guess I can just inspect
any site it doesn't really matter I just
want the JavaScript console open this
should work I'm just gonna throw this in
the console yep hello yeah why not
you can know where I am what let's try
it again
there we go yeah I had to elute I just
took a minute okay cool
so there we go now you all know where my
location is which was it's not really a
secret so evidently this is I mean
obviously this is probably not my exact
location because it's going through like
my my ISP so I'm not really even sure
where that would be but
that's what we want so here's the thing
I don't think I want a user to be
prompted with this right away and I'll
show you what if you've seen the site
that page on the site before you
probably already know why it's pretty
obvious but for everyone that's new or
hasn't hasn't seen this page before I
guess I don't even have this page open
anymore you know what I wonder if my my
dev server was shut off whenever the
power went out so it should be I
restarted it so it should be working now
and if you want to check it out it's at
catechetical calm if you can't spell
that which I have to think to spell that
and I've typed in a million times
there's a link in the description all
right so we're going to the events page
so it actually catechetical calm slash
events okay so here's the events page
right so if I were to just automatically
ask for the user's location they'd get
here and it would pop up and ask them
and they would think assuming that this
is the first time they've been to this
page they'll think why do you need to
know where I'm at right that's what I
would think hey Quincy so Quincy Larsen
just joined the live chat if you don't
know who that is
that's the founder of free code camp so
that's this is really cool that he's in
the live chat Thanks thanks for joining
the live chat and I'm geeking out a
little bit that you're in the live chat
because I remember watching Quincy do a
live chat I don't know like two years
ago or something I can't remember but
kind of early on entry code camp he was
doing like a live a live stream and
actually remember I was like on my
exercise bike working out and so
I remember exactly what I was doing when
I was watching that I don't know it
might have been one of the new year's
streams something like that oh cool so I
apologize for all the geeking out I'm
doing right here but I am gonna read
this because it's awesome
Quincy says hey Jessie longtime fan of
your work I've never gotten to watch Eli
before
I really really appreciate that I I mean
I like I really look up to your work
Quincy and everything you've done with
free code camp and it's definitely
helped me in my career I mean not just
my career but my family and being able
to provide for them so so I'm going to
stop now and get back to my stream but I
just want to let you know I really
really appreciate and I appreciate the
opportunity to stream for free code camp
it's really been amazing for me and we
kind of got a nice community built
around here so I think it's helping
people so thank you for that opportunity
all right so to get back to what we're
talking about and I know it looks like
there's a lot of activity going on the
live chat so I will get to that in a
minute but I definitely do want to get
this a little bit more done before I
really kind of dig into the questions in
the live chat so like I said you go to
this page right if the user gets
prompted here at this page for their
location so you know allow allow us to
know your location they're gonna have no
idea why we want to know their location
because the link only it's just said
events ok so they're going to have to
scroll all the way down to here before
they might have any idea of why we would
want their location so I don't want it
to just go up right off the bat so I'm
thinking there's there's maybe two
options actually three here's the three
options I'm thinking about and you'll
let me know what you think is the best
so first idea is I just have it set so
that when you scroll to this point then
this fires would so this basically fired
obviously I'm not going to console
but this is going to fire and give us
the latitude and longitude which is what
we need so that also I think might be a
little bit jarring to the user because
potentially you may be they they're
going to see that before they see this
so I'm not that's probably the lowest on
my list second option would be when they
click location for for sorting and I am
going to probably put some sort of icon
next to each header that's that's
sortable when they click here then it
would pop up and ask I'm hesitant to do
it like that though because I would like
users to be able to click here and sort
this alphabetically the third option is
I put a button somewhere around here
that says something like show nearest
events first or something I know Andrew
who's in the live chat I don't think I
saw Andrew in here yet today maybe he
can join us today but Andrew sent a link
to some nice um basically form design
let me let me share this with you if you
weren't in yesterday I didn't get a
chance to see this I know the link at
first the link as it was pasted in the
chat didn't work so maybe you didn't get
a chance to see this but this was kind
of cool
just showed a lot of different way to do
tables but what I noticed in here that I
wanted to kind of look at more and maybe
try to implement was the way they did
gets down towards the bottom okay so
here so they have this where maybe I
could do something like this at the top
of the events table here oops and you
know something like that up here
probably underneath this this uh H H tag
but right about there maybe I could do
something there that would work and it
would look nice
I kind of like how that works I still
want to keep with a material design feel
since that's what we're going for with
this site so uh you know right off the
bat I mean the button can be anything it
doesn't have to look good but then at
some point you know we're going to have
to style it so I'll leave off the
styling for later maybe maybe I'll do
that you know when I'm not streaming
depending on how long this takes but I
do want to have a button I think so that
the users not like abruptly faced with
this decision to allow me to do
something in this case know where
they're at so let me know what you think
about that or if you have any thoughts
on in terms of the UI where I should put
that for now just to get this working I
don't think there's any problem with me
just saying this is going to pop up
immediately right just for testing
that's fun and while while I was showing
you that my command line my terminal was
visible which it was covered up before
and I just noticed that I am on the
master branch and I don't want to make
changes on the master branch for this
because this is a pretty pretty big
feature you know this is not a huge site
so this features is pretty big in terms
of the scope of the site so I definitely
would do it on another branch if you're
not familiar with with using the
terminal or using git git lets you make
these like alternate versions of the
project I like to think of it as like
parallel universes so if you've ever
seen any movies or had comic books or
something that has that concept it's
like they're these little parallel
universes called git branches where it's
your project but it's it's different and
you can do whatever you want in there
and
then if you mess it up we you need to go
back you can just switch back to your
master branch so that's what I'm going
to do now I'm just going to create a
branch and I'll show you someone to type
and get get branch look let me make this
a bit bigger in case you can't see
especially I'm thinking maybe if
someone's on a phone it might be pretty
hard to see this so just a little bigger
hopefully that's enough so I already
have all these branches you see most of
them are basically they correspond to
some kind of major feature that I wanted
to put in that I knew it but would take
me a while and I'd have to go back to
masonry makes them or master and make
some little changes along the way so
let's call this one let's call a
geolocation so we're going to go get
branch geo geo location all right I was
just double-checking to make sure I
spelled that right and now when I type
get branch uh I did that I know probably
a lot of you know this and this is basic
but in case somebody's not familiar with
the command line to get to do this
basically where I'm going through this
really quickly I just type I hit the up
key the up arrow key on my keyboard and
I can go back through like my history of
commands so very useful so now I've get
branch and check it out geolocation is
there now if I want to navigate to that
parallel universe that version of my my
site I just go get checkout and there
are shortcuts for all of these commands
I'd usually just use the long ones
because I haven't really bothered to
memorize the shortcuts but just know you
usually don't have to type this much to
your commands geo and also a good tip I
can just type in geo and then hit tab
and it will autocomplete because there's
nothing else that starts with geo I
probably I could have just typed gee it
would autocomplete so that can also save
a lot of time when you're typing on the
command line and there we go now I'm on
the branch geolocation I could do
whatever I want on this branch and it's
not going to affect any of these other
branches but when I'm ready and this
feature is is ready to go and I want it
to go live I can merge it into the
master branch and now that feature will
be in master and it'll it'll get along
nicely with everything else I've done in
master and and I can push it live and
everything will work so that's kind of
the beauty of get among other things
that's what's really cool about it okay
so I didn't really intend to do like a
git or terminal tutorial but seemed like
a good time to talk about it so now that
I'm on a separate branch now I feel
confident that I can start changing
things up and I can start changing
things with reckless abandon confident
in my project is safe so let's grab this
piece of code I don't need this anymore
and we want to be on the events page so
let's go to events Jas and let's see
where we're going to put this component
in mob yeah so let's make let's make a
function kid just call it location oops
get location here and we will just
conselho this for now just so we make
sure it's working and then in let's try
putting a component didn't the only
thing I'm worried about is I don't think
this will fire on the server side I
should I should remember this by now
because I've dealt with this for months
now let me know what you think I'll
check the live chat in a minute after
the you guys hear this from the delay
I'm worried because I'm not sure that
navigator is actually available on the
server so it may throw an error but
let's just
let's see if it does get location and
I'm going to save that and we will find
out I guess quickly oops get locations I
mean it's not defined
maybe it's just what's up with this
there you go
no did I spell it wrong
all right I'm gonna check the live chat
because it should have been the delay
should have been over by now also I want
to check in that I haven't really looked
at it for a few minutes so I'm just
going to scroll up a bit just to see if
anybody's confused or if you have some
really good advice for me or anything
Oh sam says practical BIM is a book that
changes lives alright thanks for that
practical bin I'll have to remember that
one I am serious I would like to learn
them at some point I don't know if it'll
happen in the near future but I would
love to do it okay good so Sebastian
tested the API key for Google Maps and
it said refer not a lot of map error
awesome so it seems like my API key is
safe for the time being I'm guessing
though as always there's probably some
way to like spoof the URL and get it
anyway so somebody who wasn't very nice
and sees my API key probably could do
that so I should probably change it
anyway but probably not a huge deal
right now but I'll get it changed here
within the next day or so
okay I just saw when Quincy first came
in he said he noticed the stream was
going on and tweeted about it awesome
thank you alright I'm almost through
down to the bottom here with the live
chat
this there is some discussion a lab chat
about the beta curriculum for free code
camp so if you don't haven't heard about
that check that out there's even if
you've been through the old curriculum
there's a new one that's that's coming
out I don't know when but if you'd like
to help out with it check it out do some
go through a do testing and contribute
and I know like everybody's is waiting
and anticipating that new curriculum so
it would be awesome if you could help
out with that
last night I actually started I started
back in to pick up where I left off a
long time ago with free code camps with
their lessons because I got really busy
and just stopped progressing so I picked
back up and I made which one did I do
the weather I think I started redoing
the weather one I had gotten it pretty
much to where it worked before and then
I got really like worried I wanted to
make it really good instead of just
getting it done so I just scrapped that
whole one and I'm gonna redo it
okay Philip says nearby events button
near the top of the event list yeah I
think that's what it's going to happen
that's I'm going to go with well cool
Quincy said I'm honored to played a part
in your own coding journey Bo and I are
thrilled that you've been streaming so
much awesome I'm I'm glad I I wondered
if if you all were happy that I was
streaming so much or not so I didn't
want to take advantage of the
opportunity to stream on the channel so
but I'm glad if you're alright with that
I'm going to keep keep streaming you
know I think streaming Monday through
Friday is I'm going to keep it up as for
as long as it's helpful and as long as
my boss lets me do it ah-ha-ho oh and I
mentioned but if you don't know Bo does
all the like JavaScript tutorial videos
on free code camps YouTube channel and
they're awesome so check them out if you
can if you get a chance
okay Rowland says the sorting menu and
by location should trigger permission
request and probably have a subtext of
location permission required okay I
haven't thought of that but that might
be a good idea I guess I can't show you
the page right now because I'm getting
this error which I just left it at the
error for now
partly because I figured if it was some
silly mistake that I made somebody would
would just see it and let me know you
all usually catch my mistakes before I
do
I feel like I'm in a mood today to make
silly mistakes just because of lack of
sleep so I'm getting down towards the
bottom we'll see maybe somebody somebody
caught it
well we got some talk about webassembly
I'm not going to go through that right
now on the live chat but I'm super
interested in webassembly I haven't had
time to check it out too much okay so
roll on did confirm navigator is not
available in the EndNote environment so
that's what we thought a you have to use
a client-side
okay Quincy said the curriculum the beta
curriculum that I was just mentioning a
few minutes ago will come out ASAP so as
soon as possible
oh and Quincy is going to try to stream
working through it once more of it is
stable that's awesome and it says we're
also building a jsbin like interface so
you can build projects there that's
really cool
Bob asks it's actually Bob 2010 ask kind
of random question but how does free
code can make money there's lots of
ongoing development reliable servers
that set with very little ads is it a
charity I'm assuming that Quincy
answered this so let me read um and he
did Quincy said we are a donor support a
non-profit you can donate here free code
camp comm / donate so I encourage you to
do that if you can and not everybody is
in a position to donate which I totally
understand I've been there but if you're
at a point in your career in your life
where you have a little bit to spare
please you know spare some for free code
camp and I like I I definitely don't get
paid for any of this so it's going to be
going to help run you know keep up those
servers and things like that it's not
going you know in any of anyone's pocket
Amelia said you were truly an
inspiration with the strange man I
really appreciate that thank you thank
you for saying that
okay here's a good tip so cute I know
I've seen your name before and I know
you told me how to pronounce it and I
can't remember
so it's QN oox I'm not even going to try
at this time because I know I'm going to
mess it up I'm really sorry that I
forgot how to pronounce it but good tip
if you do ctrl R it's a good way to
search past types commands as well
that's useful for Less typing that's
really cool I did not know that you all
are always giving me really awesome tips
so ctrl or oh nice really cool I don't
if you can see that but it turned into
into this awesome really cool I'm
assuming controller will get me out of
it hopefully no let's see what will get
me out of this queue no haha ctrl C yeah
ctrl C when in doubt ctrl C and that
will get you out all right robot asked
to zoom into the air oh yeah sorry
I'm really sorry everybody I am I showed
you this really tiny error message I'm
sure no one could actually see it so I'm
really sorry about that so it looks like
page of Defense well there's no way I
have that many lines in that file
so I'll leave this up for a couple more
seconds and then I'm going to check the
the file as well and I've gotten to the
bottom of the live chat so it's back
back to this now
Jennifer says live-streaming is terrific
keep it up please
awesome I'm glad that uh that you like
it I intend to keep it up for as long as
it is useful to you all I will
definitely keep this up there we go uh
nico says what is the editor I'd love to
go back at some point and see like what
our streak is of how many times people
want to know about the editor which Nico
I'm not I'm not making fun of that
question anything because it's probably
one of the first times you watched I
have no problem with people asking all
the time about the editor but I find
everybody is really interested in it so
I was the same way when I watch videos
of people doing stuff I always wonder
what their tools are so don't mind
questions about it but it is Adam so it
was answered in the live chat but in
case you're watching later on can't see
the live chat the editor is Adam I have
a link so you can learn more about it in
the description all right so this has
probably been up long enough for you all
to check it out I'm gonna move this over
and see what's going on now I don't
really expect that to be much use
because obviously that's telling me that
I have an error online 1067 obviously I
don't have a line 1067 so
here's the problem I think it's needs to
be this get location and I may have to
use an arrow function here so let's do
this yep there was Donelson that works
so it's crazy that that having to use
this happens like nearly every time I
stream I have some error because I
forgot to use this and I still don't
remember it right off the bat but at
least this time I remembered without
without having to wait for somebody in
the live chat to tell me so I think I'm
getting better
oh okay so Q NOx so that I couldn't
remember how to pronounce it Q NOx okay
I remember you saying like four time
every saying that now but I don't mind
you say however you want no I want to
say it the right way so I'll try to
remember it'll be easy to remember now
that this is twice that I asked so third
time's a charm hopefully I'll remember
remember next time but this is
interesting Quincy says we hope to bring
back the live stream summits as soon as
we ship beta were all in heads down mode
right now trying to QA it and ship it so
that's that's really awesome news
there's going to be some really exciting
stuff happening with free code can soon
Alexander says put the editor in the
title also keep less people who ask now
I really don't mind when people ask
because then often the next thing that
happens is there's a discussion in the
live chat about which editor do you want
to use which i think is cool because
people get to learn more about other
people's editors because sometimes
people just use the editor that they're
comfortable with and not really make the
switch that's that's usually what I do
is it's just so much easier to stay
still right then then the move and try
to get you know use something new but if
I see everybody talking about it in the
live chat I'm way more likely to have
motivation to try it okay so check that
out so that worked excellent
let me clear this out because we did
there was an error at first
okay we didn't get the air again so I
thought maybe that had been left over
from previously so I just wanted to
verify that and since I had already
given permission here it didn't ask me
for permission again you see the
console.log automatically came up here
for my latitude longitude okay so we're
good next step and how long is this for
going on
okay so we're already at an hour in ten
minutes for this dream so the last step
here so this this step is this step is
done for it's not going to happen but we
got step one and step two are done now
let's do the comparison so here's the
thing I know I asked this at the
beginning of the stream so if you
weren't around at the beginning I'll
repeat it I have this idea and I'm not
sure if this will work that instead of
making some call out to another API to
have them compare locations what if I
can just do some sort of math to compare
these numbers and figure out which set
of numbers has the least difference
between them so basically it would be
something like like okay so we have
latitude and longitude I guess that's
the order I can't remember what order I
I wanted to get them in I guess that's
important to notice look let me double
check that since we're going to be doing
some math on it locate latitude first
and then longitude so like for instance
we can take my latitude minus the
latitude of the event and get that and
then do the same thing here and get
whatever that is and then add these two
numbers together and then we can use
that number to order everything does
that even make sense
to me it makes some sense I will have to
make sure we have some negative stuff
going on here so I'll have to just be
careful and watch out that I'm not
maybe okay I was thinking I can take the
absolute value of this but that's I
don't think that's the legit solution
because we need the absolute value right
because that's that would or we need the
negative in there to show like it would
make a big difference so we need that in
there so anyway that's my idea and it
would save us a lot of extra API calls
because remember you know we have a lot
of events down here and we need to
actually compare whoa let me make that
small you know we need to compare to
each one of these events that's showing
up here so right now it's not a huge
list but it's going to get bigger so if
this works this would definitely be
preferable because doing some simple
math is a lot faster than making you
know 100 API calls also I don't know if
if there is an API if it will let me
make that many calls all the time so I'm
going to check the live chat and see
what what your opinion is
ah Qun ox he had me in the in the live
chat or actually he or she I'm not
really sure so sorry sorry for assuming
their Baku NOC says you forgot to use
this so somebody did in the last chat
catch me on that so ruin says he says
I'm getting faster so yeah I'm gonna
faster with that
oh okay Patrick is linking to a Stack
Overflow page so I'm assuming that this
is in response to how to do the math on
on these why do I have this open twice
anyway I guess I can get rid of at least
one of those this is Patrick also says
it may be overkill for this but you need
a great circle distances okay
Mamadou I think that's how you pronounce
it sorry if it's wrong so it's like your
scroll at the bottom what did you use um
just kind of really quickly
you mean this girl like this horizontal
scroll this is just this is act this
part is all CSS if you check out the
materialise I think it's materialised
CSS calm it's a frayed JavaScript
framework or I'm sorry like a CSS
framework this javascript included -
it's comparable to bootstrap if you're
familiar with that and if they have this
responsive table class so I modified it
slightly so that it would I had some
formatting issues so I had to modify
that and then I wanted it to work on all
screen sizes but it's basically pretty
much exactly how how it was for there so
that's how I did that and then these
just take um check out the github repo I
have a function called eight scroller I
think so check out that function in the
app das file and if you have questions
about it let me know you can message me
on Twitter and I can explain it but you
check that out it's really simple I'm
just incrementing the scroll position
the horizontal scroll position and then
decrement it or decrement how do you say
a decrement or decrement anyway hey
Andrews here how's it going Andrew glad
you could make it alright we have some
other ideas here about how to do the
math patrick said i actually bombed an
interview on this exact question that
you are implementing alright well that
was just time to make up for this get it
done robot says we could probably
calculate the delta / difference between
difference and sort by sort by that
between all between locations okay all
right so let's just try some let's try
some of this math out so we can just
take these values here I guess first of
all let me over yet I need to find my
wordpress because I'd like to have more
than one example here so let me just
throw in a map location for let's do
three so two more events and then
that'll give us a couple of a couple of
pieces of data with latitude and
longitude to work with so where is this
add student though that's where I'm at
okay so that this actually this might be
a nice case to see to see if anything
weird happens in our math if the
latitude longitude match up I doubt
they'll match up exactly but cool
alright so there's a second one and
let's see I want this one to be in a
different place all right Austin Texas
that's definitely a different place that
works oh I meant to mention this at some
point in the stream so I guess I'll just
mention it now while I'm updating this I
just started I don't know if you're all
familiar with the free code camp like
groups I can't remember what they call
them officially but basically all around
the world are people that get together
and they code together and they help
each other learn how to code so you can
start them if there you can find out
about them check out the free code camp
website there's a page on there where
you can look up they use geolocation to
look up a group near you and if there's
not a group near you you can make one so
that was my case there is no
Steubenville free code camp at least
there wasn't until last night and I
created one so I don't think anybody
watching here is anywhere close to
Steubenville Ohio that's a that's near
Pittsburgh so you might be more familiar
with where Pittsburgh is but if you are
in the area ever happened to be close to
here let me know and then maybe you
could come to one of our meetups they're
actually they're building a new coffee
shop really close to where I work so
when that opens that that's probably
where we're going to meet and it's
supposed to be have really nice coffee
and great bagels so any of you are
welcome to attend if you're ever in the
area alright I don't need this anymore
just going to clean this up I don't need
ya I don't need this I probably don't
need that so let's just move this over
here and let's refresh this so that we
can make sure just verify that we have
the data ok that's first one we had it
already we have it here and we had
data here great all right so we have
three events to test this out on and I
think we can test the theory without
even writing any code because basically
I we can just do this math not by hand
I'm obviously going to use the
calculator but I don't even need that I
could probably just round this out it
doesn't need to be exact but just as a
proof of concept before we actually
start to code this because if it doesn't
work when we try to do this math there's
no sense in wasting time trying to code
it
if logically it's just not going to work
so let me actually this is it sounds
like a job for Google sheets so let me
bring over a Google sheet a spreadsheet
would be helpful here all right so I'm
gonna bring over Google sheet and I'm
just going to throw some of this data in
here very quickly alright so actually
let me go that and is that how you
abbreviate longitude no LNG there
radiating it okay I remember in school
when we learned about latitude and
longitude
I always thought about to remember which
ones which always thought like lat is
fat and like the earth look like it was
kind of fat around the middle and so I
remembered that latitude was like around
the equator and might be a silly way to
remember it but it worked for me when I
was in when I was in grade school
alright so there's one location and let
me quickly grab the other two and once
they're in there then we can just make a
formula and that way we don't have to do
the math separately for every single
one of these and since I know I I know
which ones are closer so basically it
should result the result should be that
a Steubenville obviously is the closest
because that's where I'm at and then the
next one would be Marietta Ohio and then
the farthest one away is Austin Texas so
we know what we should be and let me
grab let me grab mine and I'll just
throw that in here for now
all right should I kind of want these to
go shoot that's not what I wanted anyway
I just throw in another row I wanted a
little bit more space between here so
basically we're going to take right here
yeah we'll just put it right here so I'm
going to go equals oh this is really
small I'm sorry everyone I should have
made this a lot bigger so you can see it
okay
I'm going to glanced quickly at the live
set just to see if I'm missing something
like really obvious that somebody's
trying to tell me okay
nothing there so here's what we're going
to do we're going to take I guess it
doesn't it might not really matter which
one I take first let's go with will take
efore oops and we want a 4 minus a and
then we want to add that to the
longitude which would be f4 - there we
go
and we want these to be constant so I
don't know how you do this in Google
this is how you do in Excel you just put
like a dollar sign next to it let me
know up well I'm not it's worth to try
to see if that works or not to make this
a constant because I'm going to do this
let me see what it did
II for so it needs to be e for every
time
nope that's not it so I don't really
know how to make that constant so I am
going to have to manually modify that
which kind of stinks
b4 f4
efore it's crazy I haven't used Excel in
so long like possibly I don't know ten
years or more and I can remember how to
do something excel I've been using
Google sheets for a really long time now
and I don't know how to do that okay so
let's see 4f4 if I'd be fab alright so
let's just see if this is at all
reasonable this one yeah actually this
looks like it works out so this one was
the one from from Marietta which comes
in second place in terms of distance
this one is the one from Steubenville
which which comes in first place in in
terms of being the closest and this one
is farthest away and this is Austin
Texas so obviously this is not like a
completely conclusive test it was only
three three locations but I think that
that makes me pretty certain that this
should work if you see anything that I'm
missing oh I had to just do dollar signs
for both of them oh man I was so close
okay so I think this worked so basically
this is the formula that we need that
will give us these numbers and then we
sort by these numbers it sounds simple
when I say that but if you tuned in
yesterday and saw how much trouble I had
with trying to sort things you'll know
that it's it's not that simple at least
for me it's not that simple all right so
let me check the live chat quickly Sam
says you can use Google sheets as a free
back-end for small projects yes you can
have actually done projects like that
and it's really cool I've done it before
too stored form data and I also had one
of the students had to do a website as a
like a senior project like a senior
thesis project and he I helped work with
him on it this was just this past spring
he did the project and I advised him to
use Google sheets for a back-end and
pull it in with JavaScript like real
time it ended up being really really
cool and it worked and I when he gave
his presentation his classmates were
impressed to this site so I was really
happy for him actually got a job as a
Java developer out near Washington DC
which is awesome
yep Sam says you can write app script
and it will serve data as a web app Sam
says I'm probably going to write going
to probably write a blog post about it's
really cool awesome go for it Sam
I'll read that blog post send me a link
to it when it's done yeah you can do
cool stuff with the bag like I know I've
gotten form data and then based on that
form data I've sent the data to
obviously I've logged it into Google
sheet but then I've also sent emails out
from
from the Google sheet with Gmail so like
all automatically happening so really
cool stuff brandon says this site has
some JSF its for calculating distance
between lat and longitude cool I think I
think this is going to work the way we
did it if it doesn't I started getting
some weird stuff happening I'll check
out what some other people did but
usually I'm all for looking up with
other people did not reinventing the
wheel but in this case I thought I'd
just test my idea and even if you know
everybody else already figured this out
before me it feels good that I did it
myself and didn't look it up I mean if I
did this all the time I'd never get
anything done but everyone wants to know
how it's nice it's nice to do that so
let's at least try to get you know do
this math and get that working let me
see what time it is
thirty an hour and a half okay um yeah
let's maybe try to get a little bit more
a little bit more done so
just trying to think where I should do
this
I like this gate location function being
really simple so I don't think I'm going
to add anything to it it's just
literally going to get the location and
so probably want another function
and let me see
actually I just realized now I haven't
merged the sorting into master so
whenever I made this branch based on
master I don't have any of that in there
and I wish I did have it in there I
really don't want to do it on the same
branch but I want some of that how about
this um let me I love you I think this
is possible when it shouldn't make any
it shouldn't mess anything up but I can
just merge the branch that we were doing
the sorting on into this branch and then
I'll have this change is correct I'm
gonna try it first I'm going to save
this stuff where is my okay so in my
terminal I have it set so to up show a
little asterisks when there's changes so
it may or may not happen when your
terminal depending on how you set it up
so this tells me I type git status it
tells me what changed and now I'm going
to do git commit and I'm just going to
write am okay that means I'm going to
add and write a commit message at the
same time which I use this a lot because
normally you know I'm making really
small commits and it's fine to do that
occasionally you want to maybe break it
up and only commit certain files
you know individually so git commit am
and I'm just going to say get location
yeah get user location
that's pretty much all we did right just
got to use your location
all right and all right great everything
worked so now I'm going to merge the
other branch I forgot what I called it
and event sorted okay so let's do a git
merge event sorted oh and looks like
we're going to merge conflicts oh no we
didn't okay it's just asking me to do a
a message I don't know
I'm always really terrible about merge
messages like I just wanted to merge the
branches I don't know what to say
merge features into
geolocation all right
not sure if that's decent commit message
or not but so I can come up with right
now so I'm going to close I really kind
of wish I didn't set this to come up and
Adam it's actually a lot easier just to
have it come up in like Nano or
something right in the terminal it's
more of a pain to do it Adam so they're
ill yep
so you check this up if you haven't done
merging before with git checkout maybe
like two day the episode ended I think
two days ago we did some merging and
stuff maybe three days ago so at some
point this week I went through like more
thoroughly how to do merges so I
actually kind of wish I had merge
conflicts because I didn't get to
demonstrate that live and that would
have been probably useful if you've
never had any conflicts just to see the
process for resolving those but I'm sure
it'll happen one day when I'm streaming
so we'll get to see it at some point so
let's check out what we have here
awesome okay so this gives us a much
better picture of what this page is
actually going to look like once we get
all the sorting sorted and so here
here's what we want we're going to save
some of this data I'm gonna save this
all right so this is the part where I
may need your help because I'm feeling
really kind of tired and my brain is not
working so here's what we want to do
let's go back to our list just to keep
keep me on track so we've got this we've
got this we we need to compare location
so let's do this let's compare this and
then what I'm worried about is getting
to the point where I'm actually sorting
so I obviously need to do the comparison
save that data and then do something
with that data to sort it but then have
that associated with the actual of the
rest of the data for the event ok so
hopefully that makes sense to you all ok
so oh yeah we'll just do another
function here the scoop compare compare
location I kind of just want to say Lok
just LOC but I've already used location
so I'm just going to stick with that it
probably would have been sufficient just
to say lo all right so here's what we
want to do we want to take
are oh actually we need we need this so
we need to save
I'm thinking maybe I would just save
this into state if there's any reason
why I shouldn't just save it in the
state instead of just some variable
somewhere let me know but I I can't
really think of any reason why I
couldn't just put this in state so let's
see I'm going to break it out into two
things so it's going to be this stud and
let's use an arrow function arrow
function is going to as Patrick so
eloquently wrote in the lab chat
yesterday it's going to lexically bind
the value of this so basically this is
going to mean what I want it to mean so
you can check out I tried to explain it
I think yesterday in my stream so you
can check that out or you know look it
up for a better explanation than I gave
so now I don't want to say this right
here what I wanted to is this set state
and we're going to say curly brackets
and we want user lat and we want that to
be position
okay let me know if I do I have to
define this up here first before I do
this so let me know I'm going to finish
it out with this one but then if you
know offhand otherwise I'll just save it
and see if I get an error and then we'll
know it's state
I it seems like I'm doing this with a
lot less errors than yesterday if you're
here yesterday you know it was slightly
painful all the all the mistakes I was
making just you know syntax errors
spelling errors logic errors watch all
over the place hairs okay so let me
comment this out quickly just to save
this and see what's going on see if it
works
I don't know where I put it
events there we go
okay so Patrick says not sure if it is
required but I've always seen the
default state get initialized with all
the values okay cool I'm fine with doing
that I actually think it's it would be
helpful for someone trying to read this
if they could see everything that is is
going to end up being in state instead
of having to read through and piece
together what's there so I'm going to do
that even if it's not necessary so so
this may not be necessary but I think it
would just be good practice so how
should I data types on this will be cool
movies
I'm thinking height I don't really need
to set this to anything is there way
that I can just set this with no by you
should I just make it at this point an
empty string is that is that legit would
that be the best way to do that
man Patrick I remember you told me I'm
pretty sure you told me the same thing
yesterday Patrick just says don't call
says state twice ha ha
and I definitely forgot that it's not
like it's once Patrick reminds me of it
it's like ah that's obvious but for some
reason I just cannot remember it all
right so there we go so let's say and I
was I have Spotify going to my
headphones and I've been listening to a
song I don't even like for like three
minutes and I just realized that I hate
when that happens
ok so this should work and I just want
to make sure I'm not getting an error
anywhere oh here we go
so this is a non-event yet
let's click events hmm
I'm going to just going to reset the dev
server
there we go okay so it loads we're not
getting we're not getting any you know
air screen there I'm not getting any
errors I have the console open and dev
tools on my other screen no errors there
oh you zero oh yeah what yeah obviously
uh it's a number I'm going for so row on
both row on and Patrick you're saying
you zero it's valid lat and long
longitude yep okay so let's use zero
instead zero okay and yeah so that that
reloaded no errors at least no errors
related to that I always have a few
errors when I'm developing locally just
it basically for like I don't know where
but something with fetching some scripts
I think it has to do with me doing it
from localhost and it works when I have
it legit URL okay so Patrick saying in
this case and yesterday setting state
twice wouldn't have made a difference
but in the case where you are changing
values that are displayed in the Dom you
will cause two updates okay thanks for
explaining that so I mean I was
definitely I mean I was convinced that I
shouldn't be doing it twice just to not
just keep my code a little more simple
but that's that's also an even better
reason there so thanks Patrick for that
alright Quincy he says I better run to a
meeting but it's been a blast hanging
out with you oh I'm washing jesse code
live usually just watching time for
mistletoe speed thank you so much for
joining in today Quincy this this really
made my day and I really appreciate it
Oh see ya
all right so I too would like to would
like to be gone soon because I've been I
worked for a long time and I'd like to
go home so let's do a little bit more
with this I just hate to leave this
comment it out so let's at least get
this finished and then I will go home
maybe I'll go I'm actually I have to
review a bunch of job applications for
the web developer position that so we're
hiring a web developer here and I've
gotten a little bit behind on reviewing
the applications and I need to have them
all done by tomorrow afternoon I don't
know that I think that maybe at most
have like five more to review so it's
not a huge deal I can usually get them
reviewed like I don't know maybe 15
minutes per application it takes me
depending so some people are like really
obviously not qualified so I can kind of
very quickly rule them out okay so
here's where you want to do our math so
we want
let's see so we want in
trying to think how to do this the best
way okay so we have this saved in a
state so we're good there it just
occurred to me that I I want to be
careful I don't want this function to
ever be called if we don't have these
right because then it won't be able to
do anything it'll just give different so
I don't think we have to worry about it
right now to do what we want to do but I
need to remember there has to be some
some safeguard that if the user has not
shared their location then then this
doesn't work because I don't want errors
to come up because of that
so I'll have to think about the best way
to accomplish that but for now we just
want to do
[Music]
all right so let me think we want to get
we basically want for each event we want
a value that is the result of what we
got you know in our spreadsheet so
basically we want this value to be
attached somehow to each event so that
we can sort by it so that's going to be
the goal of this function the angle will
have this V attached to each event all
right
okay it looks like I made a mistake
earlier and Patrick is pointing this out
Patrick said he was not arguing for
using Xero he was saying that if zero is
a valid latitude and longitude no would
be a better idea it says it says this
has not been initialized okay so Brandon
says latitude longitude zero zero puts
you on the west coast of Africa and the
ocean so Patrick says yes set the
default to null test against that and
Brandon agrees with Patrick all right
thanks for clarifying that I really I
know I said this yesterday I'll say it
again today you all are very patient
with me because sometimes it takes me a
while to get what you're saying and I
really appreciate that so let me go up
here No okay cool
so here's here's where my my thinking is
I'm not exactly sure what to do I'm
trying to think how do I go about
attaching these values these values to
the events so I'll have the events
already stored there basically already
stored in State at at this point will
have
yeah we'll have the default stored did
we store it on the on load or not or
does it happen when we sort I don't
think we actually store anything in do
you store anything in state yeah we do a
component did not so in in state we're
storing this props data okay so all
everything we need is already in this
props data so it should be we should go
to set state data and then it should be
like dot dot something right so data dot
hmm
so I should do something like I'm doing
down here basically I want to loop
through everything let me show you here
so basically I want to loop basic I mean
in a sense like we could do a map so
it's going to be this state data right
and we're going to map that and then
inside of that I want to well first of
all grab the latitude and longitude make
the comparison and then the result of
that I will use this all you set state
and then I'll set I'll add yeah I think
at that point I will add something into
the state for it for this particular
particular one how would I I'm just
thinking what what would this mean
inside of here or what would be the
right
okay so I've explained it about as far
as I can think to do it let me know if
that makes sense
okay so Patrick's the Patrick's saying
this props data map okay good so at
least US was on the right track there
and then insert a distance to event
property on each event okay good so
that's what I'm thinking the only thing
I'm a bit worried about is um if I use
map will that preserve this or will I
have to just let me know so do I need to
throw in arrow function somewhere to
preserve the value of this so I can do
this at state let me know
all right so within here let's go with
oops let me do the arrow function so
that I can lexically bind this and let's
go with this state data map function and
well actually Patrick's is this props
data map is there a reason why I should
use this props data map instead of this
state data map I mean obviously the same
at least on initial load props would be
the same as whatever is in in data but
if some other sorting has happened both
after that point then they would be
different function
wait a second sorry I just get so I
think emotions sake that was probably I
just wanted to check the syntax and I
can call this event right I don't think
I will need to know the you know have
that I in there at this point I don't
think I have any use for that
all right so within this we're going to
say
okay all right so Patrick says in
response to my question about you props
or state status fine but don't forget to
capture that in a variable and then set
state with the modified data map is a
pure function that is going to return
the modifications
okay
all right so we need to do some math
first actually I need to look at the how
this is in the API so we need a CF
location map and then lat or LNG okay
I'm going to show this on my other
screen so I can see it what I'm doing
this so we're gonna say
we need this I'm just I'm going to just
type this out so I get it all out and
then we'll clean it up so I need this
state right when we do we call this user
that this state yeah use your lat
- and that's going to be event dot ACF
dot was it location map dot let okay to
do that and then it's going to be plus
okay so that was our basic formula that
we wanted to use so the result of this
is what we want to set as the value for
and what we're Patrick had a name for it
I liked it I'm trying to find it in a
live stream distance to event so I like
that name so each event okay so we want
to
all right so Patrick the last we just
got a question here when I'm going to
win will the data visualization be
available in free code Academy I'm
assuming you meant free code camp
correct so if so I don't know when the
data visualization will be available but
Quincy the founder of free code camp was
just in the chat a few minutes ago and
said that the new curriculum will be up
and running as soon as possible so no
dates given but they're working really
hard on it and it'll be up soon and I
haven't looked at the beta curriculum
for a long time so I can't say for sure
but I'm assuming that all the data
visualization stuff will be in there and
completed you can check it out though I
can't remember what the URL is but if
you you know search for the free code
camp beta curriculum you'll be able to
get a preview of what it's what it's
going to be like if you want to kind of
get a jump start you can even work
through some of the stuff some of the
the problems and the lessons okay so
back to this so let me go back to a
Patrick just said to review this so you
capture that in a variable and then set
state with the modified data okay so
oh say let distance equals there we go
and then
said state I have a feeling I'm not
doing this the way that Patrick was
trying to describe it to me so so I
fully am aware of that so just Patrick
just let me let me know we sorry and
then I was going through this at state
and let's do I need distance to event so
it's going to be this set state data no
and I know it was a shoot actually we
may have there's probably a better way
to do this but I just I think we
actually have use of this value for the
iterator because we can go data and then
put I in there and that'll give us the
one that we want right so this is state
data I and then we're gonna add the
field right so distance to offense
equals distance okay let's see Const new
data this is oh yeah cause I'm trying to
based on the wisdom that you all shared
with me about when to use constant let's
so my philosophy was like I always use
let unless I knew I wanted a Const but
it seemed like the better way is use
Const all the time unless you really
need let so I still haven't broken
myself of my first habit and but I'm
going to try to so this Stadium
oh shoot that's not what even I don't
think that's what Patrick was talking
about consciousness state data map there
we go so he was talking about which I
can use that in there anyway I suppose
because it's going to go again so here I
need
okay so don't don't set the state inside
the loop okay
I kind of was wondering about that I
assumed you would let me know when I
tried to do it if I shouldn't do it
patched it after this says state so
Const so this is we're going to do a
Const I'm just gonna write write this
how you were putted data and then after
we're going to do this set state or what
since the I'm just going to copy this
for a second
enough I'm going to copy this and when
you put in what Patrick put in there we
go this state and a new data and then I
can remove this and what I need to do is
then should this be returned instead of
actually making this a variable
do I need that is that not necessary
here
I guess I'll hit save and see see what
happens all right well now there is yet
so that's a good sign but what I really
need to see is sue
this is you need to okay so Shah says
yeah I've returned it good okay Patrick
says you need to return it but you need
to set the new property with the
calculated value this state
yeah you're right I just I just read he
said you need to set the new properly
calculated value so I turned my head
over and just saw what I was doing here
I realized it and then turned back and I
saw Patrick said that wait such your
data is yeah oh man this is the same
thing I did yesterday I think I just
tried to push it and get too much done
when my brain was just not ready just
too tired for all this um okay what was
I I did want to ask really quickly so
these are the dev tools for react so I
wanted to show them and also ask a
question so you have a react tab I
forget if it's some sort of extension I
think that you have to download for this
to work but I just wondered I cannot I
can see props but I don't see anywhere
for state although I wondered perhaps I
just over wrote on my state and that's
why I can't see it oh no
Lynden just joined us and said can't
believe I got a notification two hours
Ben I'm really sorry I am I set the
notifications to to go out beforehand so
I'm not sure if I can do anything to
remedy that
except maybe create the event earlier in
the day so today I created it kind of
late because I had a Twitter poll on the
topic so but it was all kind of late I
spent all morning in meetings so
everything was delayed more than I
wanted it to so I'll try to get the
event scheduled earlier in the day and
hopefully that will stop the the
notifications from going out late as
well okay alright so Patrick is giving
me lots of stuff here let's let's go
back to this Patrick says event distance
shoe event
equals cocked in return event
all right so distance all right Lyndon
says it's okay I'll catch up tomorrow
Cheers
all right I'm just I'm going to read out
a comment just come up not necessarily
related work on what I'm just going to
read it right now to give my my brain a
slight break here Manny is saying hi
this helps me a lot and thank you Jesse
some things are small and the videos
help me review over and over until I see
what you are clicking and it is fun
Jesse I am new and nothing I know
nothing at all all right cool thanks for
watching yeah I'm glad you're getting
something out of it I think I said the
beginning this is kind of more advanced
stuff so if you're just learning this
might be kind of difficult I'll try to
do my best to explain and yes you saying
some things are really small - watch it
- see what I'm clicking so um yeah so I
mean I'll try to keep the you know
everything as large as I can in terms of
font size and everything but let me know
if it is really too small and you can't
see all right so let's finish this up so
the then distance to
all right so we need poops
okay so we need to return the event so
let me read out Patrick saying for those
of you watching later on so he's saying
we need Rohan's has got to go really
sleepy yeah what is it like two or three
o'clock in the morning where you're at
probably I can't believe you stayed up
this late as it is so yeah get some
sleep I'll see ya actually not tomorrow
I won't be streaming tomorrow because I
will be hopefully taking a nap because
I'm going to drive through the night
about eight hours to take my family to
the beach for vacation so won't I won't
be streaming tomorrow but it might be a
week before I am I stream again so
thanks for staying up this late and
hanging in there Rohan all right sorry
Patrick I keep messing around and you're
being really patient with me so
all right so event so from what I'm what
I'm thinking the Patrick is saying here
is that we need to return where is that
I'm losing it here okay um then return
events okay so event dot distance to
that return event
you said
event distance to event equals oops
let's do this all right this is making a
little bit sense to me so hopefully I'm
doing this right and then we're going to
return event awesome and then that's
what's going to be so event now this
event uh with and I guess I don't need
this huh so this event is now the value
of new data right
and okay Patrick's Patsy says there's a
big thunderstorm rolling in so might
lose power well I hope you don't lose
power for your sake and for my sake
because you're helping me out alone
right now so she's rolling it over the
mountain where if you don't mind me
asking where where are you at Patrick I
mean just in general if you get if you
have mountains around you
all right so Patrick let me ask you
okay East East Tennessee cool I'm from
I'm from West Virginia myself so not not
super far from Tennessee I ex obscenity
is there any point I don't think there's
any point where West Virginia borders
Tennessee but it's pretty close inside
the southern point of West Virginia so I
have been to Tennessee a few times
really nice my wife has as family in
Tennessee okay so Patrick am I am I
doing this right so far
at least in this area oh cool
Patrick says drives through West
Virginia on the way to see family and
Pittsburgh really cool yeah they said
I'm about to drive from where I'm at to
Pittsburgh only takes about 30 minutes
it depends on where at in Pittsburgh I I
mean I can get to the like the west side
of Pittsburgh in about 30 minutes takes
longer of course to get you know through
the city over to the east side but that
puts brings a cool city if anybody has
ever around Pittsburgh or anything let
me know
I don't know I don't know if we'll get
to meet up or what if that'll be if that
will be possible oh cool Coraopolis
patches Coraopolis by the airport oh
yeah so that's only about a half hour
drive from where I'm at awesome
and it's actually only about I don't
know 15 25 minutes away from where I
grew up which was right on the border of
Pennsylvania and West Virginia at one
point in my I could walk in my backyard
and cross the border into Pennsylvania I
used to like to stand like right in the
line between West Virginia and
Pennsylvania and like say like one of my
feet was in one state and the other was
in the other state so when I was a kid I
thought that was really cool
uh-huh okay awesome so Patrick says
thinks that's right uh.okay log it
alright cool
yeah this he was flown here means she
want me to log it mean like console.log
it I'm like nervous now every time I
type something in I'm going to look over
and Patrick's gonna type in like lol
what are you doing now pass is really
cool about everything in patient with me
but it's happened quite a few times oh
cool you went some Patrick went to Moon
middle school for a year in seventh
grade oh yeah and I know yeah definitely
been in that area plenty of times so
that's really cool that I have cousins
that went to West Allegheny high school
up there so not not in the same area
Pittsburgh obviously but you might be
familiar with that if you were if you
were up in that area
oh cool Brian lives in Pittsburgh -
awesome
did anyone go there is a tech conference
in Pittsburgh did did you happen to go
to that Brian or you I just found out
about it like two days before it
happened and they had already stopped
selling tickets I really wanted to go
and maybe like do some interviews like I
did for a conference a couple weeks ago
but maybe next year okay Patti says this
is a passing fad she says I'm old this
was a long time ago oh actually I keep
like thinking wise why won't I see
anything happening I'm never actually
calling compared location anywhere
so that actually here's what I should do
why not call I said I wanted to make
sure that we had the users location
before we did this so let's just call
compare location from within here and I
mean right now this is this is happening
right away but it will happen once the
user actually clicks on something at
some point yeah Brian asks which
conference I can't remember what it was
called um I just saw it on Twitter
somebody tweeted about it but yeah there
was some sort of tech conference they
have lots of different stuff like frying
stuff backends - all different kinds of
like programming things and it looked
cool it was held at some like college
level a community college or something
in Pittsburgh yeah so it looks really
cool what I'd like to go next years I
did I followed the conference Twitter so
if you check out my Twitter and my
followers it's it should be one of the
most
and accounts that I followed actually
think it might be cool to like maybe
apply to speak at at that conference
I've never spoken at a at a tech
conference so I think that would be
really cool and I used to teach so I'm
used to speaking for a long time and I
guess I do the same thing when I do my
streams so I don't think it would be
like too much of a stretch for me it
might be fun
must have to think of a good topic that
might be helpful to people
all right this computer location all
right let's try it this saved it nothing
happens
I saw no change at all in in dev tools
or anything all right I think I think
that's because my server once again is
frozen
top test Patrick says he's terrified of
public speaking more power to you and
anyone who can do it
oh well it's I don't know I've never I'm
not gonna say I've never gotten like
that nervous feeling beforehand but I've
never been like really really nervous
about public speaking before so I guess
I'm kind of lucky that I I just really
never had that so it's not like it's not
really any credit to me of being brave
or anything because I've never really
felt a fear about it so it's oh man so
that's not let me tell you what happened
this is definitely not the result that I
wanted so I'm doing something wrong
somewhere oh I get yeah obviously I
didn't fix that um see it's giving me
well actually it's saying the fetch
failed that should not happen that that
seems an unrelated issue to what we're
doing
I'll show you what I was when I'm
getting meaning all these hairs
let's see let me just get rid of this
for a second
[Music]
the old debugging by commenting things
up not the most efficient way to do it
but it works eventually all right so I
mean that did at least bring this stuff
back so that's good
all this alone and to get rid of this
bring it back up
yeah
Oh
okay we're die this is looking more
useful I forgot to probably forgot to
say 39 and that's just 39 what am I
doing wrong here
it looks like
I'll show you the air again but it looks
like it's saying
I guess you cannot repro preset state of
undefined and
so is this saying that this is not
working why is this oh I'm not exactly
sure but it could it be since I'm
calling it from in here I also need to
make this and arrow function I'm not
really sure but why not why not make
them Oh arrow functions and then they'll
match okay so I didn't get the error
again so this is still the old error so
this is all the new stuff did not get
the air so that's that's good let me do
a refresh and get rid of all this stuff
just to be sure I'll show you what I got
okay cool so
didn't get the error but oh and here we
go got it again so I did it was just a
laid
hey all right fabien cheer hey how's it
going hey I I want to know
fabien or fabian or how do you prefer
your name to be pronounced I know it's
hard to type that out but try if you
could I would love to say it correctly
so let me know also thanks for joining
i chen says hello I just saw the stream
but have to go now alright well thank
thanks for stopping in for a bit uh yeah
you have a nice day too this is L looks
like lol lol so as I can't speak in
public but also I need a job so that I
can get surgery Wow
I hope it's not like anything super
serious but and now the message is
retracted I'm sorry if you didn't want
me to read that out now let's see
messages retracted so sorry about that
actually just so that everybody knows I
do kind of read out the live chat a lot
so if you have something you don't
really want to be read out direct
message me on Twitter and then I won't
share anything from a direct message on
Twitter if unless you tell me like go
ahead and share it so anyway hopefully
though you all if you're trying to get a
job in programming hopefully this helps
you a little bit or maybe helps you make
a decision as to whether or not you want
to do this I don't claim that this is
what it's like for all developers but
it's what it's like for me and
a front-end developer transform function
position to position
all right let me let me this out here so
I'm looking
so hey so I asked Fabian how to
pronounce his name and he just typed his
name in I so is Fabian okay I'm really
thinking there's no way that that's how
people pronounce that in France
okay so anyway he said transform
function position to position and the
arrow function so we're sorry for not
getting this at all but if Fabian where
where are you directing me to change
this because I'm not sure I like the
error message I'm getting is for this
line but I wasn't sure if it had to do
with anything I'm doing up here since
I'm calling it there you transform arrow
functions to use this set state oh okay
now I see where that talked about this
here I just totally didn't didn't see
that at all sorry about that now that I
see this your previous message is super
clear shoot you know what I mentioned
something about that earlier and then
totally forgot so alright so let's shout
out now whoa what just happened I got
some errors here today did I mess it up
- this isn't whoops
mine 35 ok lysee lm35 what am i oh ok
shoot I forgot to take out function
sorry about that that was a silly
mistake ok
yeah I think thanks to - and I just saw
there's a delay in the you know between
what what I'm doing in and what you all
see in here so but Sebastian found that
and let me know what it was
he's dystonia okay and also below found
it as well
Brandon says it's pronounced baby on
Fabian according to google okay so maybe
I'm not that far off
would I for some reasons it's still
showing me what I had before
your server already Sebastian says it's
like a five-second delay that's not bad
at times it's been like more closer to a
minute so I guess that's good
actually the stream the stream health
has been good you know the whole time so
not bad I was actually really worried
because all the thunderstorms here that
I wouldn't even be able to stream so
we're having power outages but nothing
nothing has happened so far this has
been a really long stream all right
there we go
okay awesome see make sure we have this
great okay so it did load everything
all right let's see
all right so my
yes I said
see my console.log is not firing so why
am I not
actually I should probably now I don't
want to enter a function here right
because I want this to be actually
what's inside this
Patrick says maybe you need to revoke
geolocation also we'll ask you again
yeah actually now that I think about it
it should've I guess I took that
console.log out then I get location
console look I'm gonna actually want to
add it back in because I want to see if
this is doing anything I'm just I guess
I don't need both latitude and longitude
I just need those states
yes this get location
yeah this is not
hmm
it's not working let me show you what a
venir so I'm not getting that
console.log of the latitude like I
should be no I'm not getting anything
I wonder I'm just going to console up
you know basically anything
it's not showing anything I am my my
thought right now is what if I've
exceeded the amount of times I could use
this you know and like I just refreshed
the page way too many times maybe so I'm
wondering if this is just hanging and
not not getting down to where it needs
needs to be to run anything else
yep all right so see that worked when I
loved that when I put it up above above
here but let's see if I can find
and I'm just going to verify that if I
put it down here it's not going to do
anything so I say that I'm going to do a
refresh no actually it did work this
time I don't know what happened before
and why it didn't work and then it works
okay sorry Patrick I just saw that your
last message so location
please ask okay all right let's see
okay awesome so it asks
okay so at least you know this this
portion worked and so then I'm assuming
but we'll check bit if I log position
that I will in fact get the position and
on either I got to remember to keep
refreshing because it's not going to run
that again I think just if I reload the
modules there we go
there's the position the Geo position
objects great alright so that is running
all right line 45 needs to be an arrow
function okay so it does I'd considered
that and then thought it might mess
things up so hopefully this is it and
this fixes it I'll bring this over so we
can all see the result and the console
okay at that that's it we should have
gotten more than that right so you
should have gotten after this it should
have ran compared location which should
have logged event correct yes
at least
all right shoot starting to run out of
ideas
this is
well I just checked my phone have 11
slack messages doesn't look doesn't the
biggest anything that's serious I think
it's all just people joking so I'm not
going to look at them
okay so Fabian says this set state
doesn't immediately change the state
okay so where am i with this set state
so talking about this this time when I
use it up here on line 37
yielding says do you use routes there's
a set state also read those the dome
okay I'm not sure which you mean by raus
yielding could you explain it a little
bit more so I can give you a better
answer try to love this state okay
and this is turning into what the heck
much more of an epic stream that I
expected I mean I should have expected
it more I've never done this before so
well my plan for the stream is I know
what I want to happen but I don't know
how to make it happen then I should
expect it it could take a while I think
my dev server just needs reset I I know
I've said this a million times already
but I just I really need to figure out
why this keeps happening because it's
like occasionally it happens frequently
and it's annoying sometimes I go pretty
far without it happening okay I should
be working now if i refresh yeah
doing this okay but at least we got
state okay so that's what we wanted so
here we're a console of the state right
here on line 38 so let's see okay we do
in fact have user like you usually want
okay so we have that so we have this
state data it has it has the data in it
so I kind of wish it didn't and then we
would have found it rough
okay Ewan is explaining what he meant so
react router allows you to have routes
for multiple pages just curious if
you're using that to use the react
add-on for Chrome I do have the react
add-on for Chrome it but I'm having I
don't use it a lot I'm not that familiar
with it is there something in here that
would help at this point let me know and
I'll I'll check it out in here I really
want to know like should should I not be
able to see like I can see props right
here is there any way to see state right
here so I don't have to console.log
state
and then answer your question yield and
I'm not using react router for this
project because I'm doing this I'm using
next Jes with this project and it comes
with their own router I am doing some
custom routing so if you check out the
github repo for this look at the server
JS file you can see some of the custom
routing I'm doing I needed to do some
parameterised routing because there's
some like blog style pages going on so
but basically it's just the default
routing from next J s with with the
exception of slight modifications but I
would like to learn other like more
about react router and other ways to do
it because I think I think I'm limiting
myself by not you know definitely by not
learning that I could be doing more
dragos I'm using atom from from that's
from github right yeah get up mix atom
oh okay so this goes so Fabian said
you're logging stay inside location
which is triggered seconds after calling
compare location okay so should we try
it somewhere else should I try
should I try somewhere else maybe I
don't know here or
the right it should be oh oh goodness
okay so when I log it from there
there's nothing in data all right so
let's check this out so inside here it
has the data inside here no data so
we're actually calling get location
first and then from in there is compare
location so what's happening what is
happening between here and here that's
wiping that out
okay
so Fabian is saying I need to move this
function call inside here your refresh
be Odin says where is your state set do
you have a main component that is
housing the state and you're accessing
it from a sub component all right so
that yeah that did it in terms of you
know now we're getting we're getting
data here all right but now we cannot
read property ladder undefined and
that's on line 48 so we're getting
somewhere cuz that's a new error are
suing here and then a shiv location map
oh shoot I know it's happening I don't
have I don't have the set for all the
events because we only did it for three
of the events so it's it's iterating
through the first three once it gets to
four it's saying this is undefined so um
I guess I need to let me see what it
looks like if I don't have it so here's
here's the what's this looks like let me
scroll down a bit find one that doesn't
have this so ACF okay so it just doesn't
have it all so if I check for has a CFS
in property so I'm going to do this and
say
[Music]
if I don't know there may be a better
place to put this F statement so this
OUP's event the ACF has property
that's the right one right has in
property I don't know why I didn't
autofill that for me and then we want
location map then we want to do that
okay so that should at least get rid of
that error because it won't attempt to
read that
assuming that that was the right name
for that function
Brandon says I think Figgins on the
right track try moving compare location
call to within the geolocation callback
Pedro says it's not really 9 te it's
just Visual Studio codes this is
referring to to Adam actually uh
actually Pedro I'm using Adam and you're
right yeah Adam it's not a night it's
not really an IDE it's um it's just a
code editor but yeah I mean oh nice I
didn't even see what happened because I
was paying attention there but that that
is awesome it's progress
all right great so yeah this is this is
good so you can see that was what was
happening the first three actually have
have values and okay so we see here so
it did its thing it did the math and it
actually added now a distance to event
so this is this is now exactly where we
wanted on this object so now we can sort
by this so
I assume ease
where my
I want to double-check the state so I
don't need this anymore here because
that worked but I want to check the
state at the end here
just to be sure
and let's see check this one here we go
okay so we do have it it is there
awesome so I guess I don't need this
then because the state is yeah Yoda and
said this is where TDD saves your sanity
so test-driven development you are
correct
I definitely want to learn how to do
test-driven development and use it and
it would definitely be worth the time
spent and learning it
yeah okay so Amelia asked the way you
fixed is that some events don't have a
Latin long right yeah actually um I
don't think I really explained what I
was doing so sorry about that when I did
we were getting an error and it was
saying like basically it can't find I
forget what the exact error was but
basically it was telling me that this
did not exist for some of these events
which made sense because I didn't
actually put in a value for some of
those events so when I did this so I
checked the API data just the the raw
data here let me bring it on the screen
just to step you through what happened
so I checked it here and I saw that ACF
you can see it didn't even have like a
blank value or anything it just didn't
have it at all it did not have that
field so I went in and said if event dot
a CF has on property location map so
this this basically says if if this is
even a property here it's just like it
says right so then go ahead and do this
calculation otherwise just skip skip
down to you know do the return event and
then that ensures that it's not looking
for this when it doesn't exist and then
that fix the error okay
Amelio s I was wondering those the
Google API puts puts the data when
creating the new event and setting the
address I'm not exactly sure what you're
asking Emilio
could you explain a little bit more so I
give you good answer please
okay so Patrick's saying you can do an
else on the check for location map add
distance to event to those without it
and set it to infinity then at the end
of your map sort to your sword
okay so basically so basically saying if
an event doesn't have a location it's
it's going to show up at the end then
Fabian's is argue mutating the state
without calling set state react won't be
aware something has changed Patrick says
you're very close to having this done
I'm glad about the head Oh Amelia says
where does the Latin longitude come from
for the events okay yeah so I'll show
you so here's what it is coming from so
I have here in WordPress
a Google map where you can put in the
the city and then so you put it in there
and then what you get from the API is
assuming you've put it in you get this
here and that information has come from
the Google Maps API of the latitude and
longitude so that's where I get that
data from hopefully that explains that
answers your question
okay so go to the Patrick saying map is
a pure function where is he behaving
state directly and Fabian says event
object is updated so we're talking about
my mat here
please
Patrick replied right but map is pure so
it is operating on a copy emelius has
got it thanks all right awesome glad I
thought I answered your question yo Dan
said I'd learned mob X or redux for way
better state management using set state
has disclosed yeah I want to go with mob
X I um I was at a conference recently
and I I listened to a talk about Redux
and mob X showing like the differences
between them and how to basically show
comparing like how you would do the same
thing in both and I think I definitely
want to go with with mob X so when I get
a chance I want to want to learn that
Yoda says mutating state is dangerous
anyway alright so there's some
discussion going on about this portion
in particular this in that would react
be able to pick up on this change in
state right is that the yeah I think
that's that's it
so so I think Fabian saying that since I
didn't use this set state to change the
state here react won't know about it
so should
should I then instead of setting it here
should I use that state would that fix
it could I use that state inside of this
and would it work if let's say I just
changed this to set state and then made
it distance to event
at this point I think I'll just try it
and see if it see if it works so this is
state distance to event
okay now I guess an answer so probably
shouldn't have done it
Patrick says you take all your data then
set state favi says you need to clone
event objects all right so let me get
rid of what I just did here all right so
we need to mutate everything and then
you set state to update it all at once
instead of trying to update it every
time this for every every poke every
event right I'm pretty sure that's the
same okay so let's not
you decline oven
yotan says this is why mob ex and
amiable state makes things a lot cleaner
and easier easier to manage lots of to
Tories around yeah uh yielding yeah
definitely I mean I'm not I don't I
don't disagree with you at all if you
haven't seen any of the previous streams
so I got to get some water my throat's
uh starting to get really sore so
basically the story is for this site is
it was a surprise project that I did not
expect it was someone else's project an
outside company was supposed to do it
and basically it ended up that it needed
to launch and I needed to be able to do
it really quickly so yes I mean if I had
more time I would have done this
differently and there are definitely
areas where I I would say like I made
decisions based on what could be done
more quickly and and that was based on
what I already knew how to do knowing
that I didn't have the time to properly
learn something new so but I definitely
do want to learn mob X so the next time
I do a project like this which there
there are several projects of the future
that will probably use the same kind of
setup I will definitely try to learn mob
X and incorporate that okay Patrick says
my bad I totally lift on the clone step
Patrick I kind of think like probably an
hour ago at this point you were
mentioning something about that doing
something similar to that so I think I
erased that part that we were attempting
to do so it's probably my fault Yoda
says you have a store file and all your
is there and then you use this bet yeah
okay cool
see Yunnan was describing mob X so yeah
I am off to look I took a lot of notes
at the talk that I went to that talked
about mob X and hopefully they're going
to release the videos for that talk at
some point it was syntax Kahn was the
conference so then maybe I can watch the
video again and it will or check out a
lot of the other video tutorials
Fabian says it's important to clone
because set state will compare old state
with new one but if you alter the old
state reactor won't be able to know what
really changed okay cool so I'm going to
ask a very probably a noobish question
here but just for the sake of getting
this done on time what's the best way
like how should I clone this in terms of
like what woodson hey do I use Yoda and
also ass on this site do you know the
users because I 11 still does not
support es6 classes unless you use
babbles so yeah I mean I am using babble
so next Jas automatically handles a lot
of that stuff so actually don't yeah we
tested this site in IE 11 at some point
I think we went through some testing so
yeah we did so it doesn't actually the
worst part of the site is some of the
CSS because I'm using flexbox for some
things and that doesn't work in IE 11 so
[Music]
yeah so I mean realistically my boss is
not concerned about me making things
work in IE 11 his his viewpoint is it
would probably be better for people to
just update their browsers anyway if
possible so and they're probably used to
other parts of the internet work not
working correctly so it somewhat does
depend on our audience though
realistically but
in general if it's not going to cause a
huge problem with our audience
it does seem almost like uh I don't know
in a kind of in a way it seems like it's
better I'm torn between us because part
of me is like don't support ie 11 and
put the pressure on everyone to upgrade
I 11 and use something that's better and
I mean let's face it more secure right I
mean you have less of a chance of
getting malware and stuff if you have
into a browser - so it's not just the
like I want to do cool stuff
you know forget your old browser it's
people need a reminder that you should
be updating these things but then the
other part of me is like I want
everybody possible to be able to have
the best experience on my site so I want
to support all these older browsers so
I'm a little bit torn between the two so
I just I just kind of consider who the
audience is and like when I make sites
internally for the university here I
have no problem just throwing up a band
like a pop up at the beginning saying
like hey you're using an old browser you
need to update this because I mean
that's the security issue like I've had
people using insanely old browsers like
browsers that haven't been updated in
seven years and that's just unacceptable
like at the University I have gotten
like bug reports and it says that
they're using browsers that are seven
years old and that's just great we can
like we can't have browsers that are
seven years old running on our computers
here at the University so at some point
we just have to force people to update
so anyways
sorry for the rant on the side there
okay so fibia did answer my question
that was more to the point before I went
on my little sidetrack King thing here
so he's saying oh cool you're using the
spread operator yeah awesome
always love an excuse to use new
features alright so let's do this
so Fabian where we at cause event clone
event okay so let's do
I'm assuming it has to be in here this
seems like the only reasonable place to
put it to me not that I thought that
much about it but uh Const event
equals okay all right so this is the
spread operator yo Dan says spread
operators love and template strings yeah
for sure for sure I agree with you 100%
okay so number one is this actually
where I supposed to put it I think so
number two we have event clone so does
that mean now I should change this to
event cloned and then and then at some
point after I've changed event cloned
then I set state I think I got this now
I have the concept of what's happening
now
let's let's try we're at and now I'm a
bad turn Vivint cloned and this set
whoops state events oops
is this what I really want No
because I don't have a vent I want
yeah this isn't what I want I messed up
at some point right
okay I did forget there we go clone
event cloned distance to event all right
now we're returning from this event
clone great and
No
[Music]
am i good so online 52 I have the right
idea here of I Andre since there's an
error on line 44 where I got with let's
see saying objects are not editable hey
hi Andre welcome I don't I don't
remember seeing you commenting before if
you have sorry but anyway welcome
welcome to the live stream thanks for
for helping out okay spread operators
for arrays okay and this is not not
arrays oh it is first time awesome Andre
well welcome welcome I appreciate you
you watching um is this your first time
in case you didn't realize it already I
I don't claim to be an expert this is
just me doing my daily work and
occasionally like today I attempt to do
something that I really have no idea how
to do and usually everybody in a live
shot gives me a lot of help sometimes I
do things where I really do know what
I'm doing and it's probably more more
useful to everyone watching this is one
of the days where I'm getting a lot of
benefit from from your expertise alright
awesome so Fabian saying the spread
operator works also with objects now
cool
oh okay so my last question I think I've
I've changed events up nope I need to
change it I guess it doesn't really
matter if I change it here or not but
I'm going to just for consistency event
clone okay
if not use cloned equals object to sign
event and it's the same okay so
Fabian's giving an alternative in case
the spread operator is not going to work
for this so I mean actually this I guess
I can just eight of them wait a second
alright here's where I am oops sorry
this said stay I missed a few things in
the live chat here I gotta go back and
see what's going on Patrick says this
set state new data and Fabian says and
finally this dot set state the data new
new date Patrick don't forget to name
the property in this case yes and
filibus what do you use to expose
advanced custom fields to WP API there's
a plug-in for I mumbled that sorry
filibus what do you use to expose
advanced custom fields in the WordPress
API there is a plug-in to expose
advanced custom fields so I don't
remember which plug-in I use for sure so
I can I can check it out when I finish
this I kind of want to finish this right
now before I go back to the WordPress
thing but if you stick around for a
couple of minutes hopefully it only
takes a few minutes to get this this
working and then I can check WordPress
for you before I end the stream ok
Patrick's new day date of the yotan said
I tried you spread on an object it
doesn't work Patrick says are you using
it using a transpiler and fieldin says
yes okay Philip just says was wondering
if I wrote the plug-in or if there was a
plugin yeah I didn't write that plug-in
I got it from from somewhere else so
welcome Bob okay alright so this is a
big discussion still about the in the
live chat about the spread operator
and whether or not this will work so
actually let me
let's just check this out hopefully I
didn't do it a lot to break a ha shoot
I've worked I did too much to break this
so
just get get rid of this for now just so
I can see what is going on
whoops
you need
and actually I need this stuff
okay that should do it
I'll shoot this
okay so just I don't know if this will
help your discussion about the spread
operator but basically I am console
logging event cloned just to see what
it's giving me and here's what I get I
get this object here with all my stuff
is that what Fabien is that what you are
expecting to see
okay so base today see where yeah oh
yeah sorry everybody I kind of ignored
the live chat for a minute because I
just thought there's definitely one way
to solve this discussion just
console.log it and see what's going on
okay so at least we now know that yes
indeed we do have a copy of event now so
here's here's my question so this part
I'm assuming is correct the part that
I'm still I don't know about is now I
need this after this all happens I need
to set the state how do i how do I do
that I'm sorry if you've already put
this in the live chat this is one of
those times where I'm honestly slightly
lost right now so please be patient with
me I will say this though when I do
streams like this where I am kind of
lost for a lot of the time I learned a
lot and I often don't don't really need
like the next time I do it I remember it
and can look back and do it so all right
so Fabian saying am Patrick you're both
saying saying this which okay now that
now that you put that in there I
remember you both pasted something like
you pasted that in before or you wrote
that in before so sorry for making you
do that again
so this which is this the right location
for this I mean I'm going to save it and
just see if I get a bunch of errors all
right lots of errors
now you Yoda and says struggle helps yes
it does for sure and then it takes a
long time it can be painful but it takes
some time okay so alright so Patrick
saying yes this is Rice place to do that
oh my goodness
now it just clicked for me so in case it
was confusing to anyone else watching
here's what just clicked for me this may
have been obvious to you but the whole
time I'm thinking like that I'm gonna
have to say set set state and somehow
I'm going to set the state of event to
event clone but then it occurred to me
like wait a second there is no state
event right this is this doesn't make
any sense
forgetting completely that this whole
thing we named new data right so anyway
um yeah so I just needed to set data to
new data and not anyway so hopefully you
can see that that I finally just
realized that so anyway I wish I would
have seen that like 15 minutes ago oh
well when stand at this for a long time
now so okay but I am alright let me show
you the areas that I'm getting right now
and
so unexpected character at line 54 this
at state 8 a new data
[Music]
yeah
Fabian says we had some some people
asking about my code editor again
Fabian's has put it put Adam in the FAQ
I have it in the description actually so
I don't mind people asking about it but
today is it's actually like every half
hour so I think somebody asked about it
which is totally cool I mean somebody
who's never watched the show before you
know the stream obviously wouldn't know
I'm actually I kind of like that more
people Newt it tells me that new people
are joining because they're asking about
the effort Patricks has to be fair I'm
not talking commenting answering
questions at typing while trying to code
you have the harder job here yes well
that makes me feel a little bit better
thanks for that Patrick I will say like
for sure I work I definitely work faster
when I'm not streaming but I think it's
a good trade-off because I learn a lot
when I do streams like this so I think
the long run net effect is that Morgan a
lot more gets done and the end result is
a lot better than it would have been if
I would just kind of do my own thing all
the time and not stream especially with
some of the pool requests that you all
have submitted they're just really
amazing and I actually like I go through
line by line and try to understand what
you're doing and I've learned a lot from
that I really appreciate that okay so I
showed you my my error here so I had
some going on with this set state maybe
I messed something up when I was
changing some things let me see okay so
that's good
yeah this
yeah that looks good
Who am I missing
I think I'm I'm missing a friend
no I wasn't it was right here I was
mistaken so that yeah this is closed
this is closed all right said it's not
like some obvious uh you know like
missing curly curly bracket okay I'm
going to check hey being says yes
Korea's just Brandon says streaming is
smart
you get free help while getting paid to
do the job yeah yeah I mean I kind of
like to think that I help people too but
you are right Brandon a lot of times I
I'm getting help I'm getting a lot of
help and that's true I'm getting paid
for it that's why I did have when I
first started streaming i had some
people ask about like like giving me
donations and stuff and i I mentioned a
couple times I'm getting paid right now
because this is my regular work so I
just I don't really feel like I should
take any money if I'm getting paid to do
this at some point if I start doing like
lots of streams like from home on my
free time then maybe I'll think of some
way to make money off of it if anything
justice I guarantee if I spent my time
at home doing streams and videos my wife
would get upset pretty quickly but at
least if I could say like hey I'm
bringing in more income she would be a
little bit happier I don't think she's
listening to this if you are listening
back then you could let me know if
that's the case
oh okay Fabian all right I I did copy so
Fabian says did you copy this that state
from chat it seems an invisible
character has been put in yes oh yeah
okay that explains it so so that's why I
say unexpected character and it just has
this right right here
okay so awesome so let me um let me just
get rid of all this and I'll type it out
and then that way I should be pretty
sure that I'm going to do it so this dot
set state and I'm gonna go ADA new data
okay
you can see I'm still trying to break
myself with a semicolon habit if you
notice occasionally when I get to the
end like this I tab over I go over cuz
I'm getting ready to put the semicolon
in but I've stopped myself
alright let's see alright so I'm not
getting that error again
I got a different error but I don't
think it's um I don't think it's
affecting the page negatively all right
so let's check this out let me show you
what I got I got this error but I think
that's at events for what the heck is it
events for oh it's some other sticking
up yeah that's that's probably just has
something to do with the hot module
reloading and this occasion I get weird
errors with that but of course I never
get them you know on the live site
because I'm not doing the hot module
reloading there okay
that's better cool so let's
now that we have this this is a date a
new data okay
awesome job Fabian and catching that by
the way that was definitely the problem
Umberto's says yay for non display
characters I'm currently doing a lot of
parsing on slash n such a and slash F
and my current project ok so at this
point I really wanted to actually get
the sorted sorting working but honestly
it's like almost 6 o'clock p.m. at my
time and I got in like suddenly how long
have been here at this point um I'm
definitely I'm definitely way past the
amount of time that I am supposed to
work and I expect that my wife is
wondering where I am
so I think I'm going to cut it short I
really hate to leave it like right in
the middle like this especially since
I'm not going to stream for a while so
I'm going to do my best
when I I'm I probably won't get to it
for till after I get back from vacation
but I want to do my best to actually not
make this work with the sorting and
thanks actually Patrick says sort a be a
distance to event B distance to band
heito distance to then okay so actually
maybe I will sort it because Patrick
just gave me what I need in here so um
let's see
so Patrick if I do the sorting
all right so let me paste in with
Patrick just just so everybody can see
this Patrick just
pasted this and but you need an else on
location map that sets the distance to
event on others okay cool
yeah I'm definitely I'm not gonna have
time to implement this so I'm going to
leave this in here like this just so
that I mean normally I don't really like
leaving in like partial code and
commenting it out but in this skate this
is probably the best place for me to put
it so I'll actually remember so at least
I'll know where to go from so this is
that you know put it above set state
which makes sense so that basically if
you're watching just just for
explanation of in case I don't finish
this in a stream and I stood around
basically if we sort before we set new
data then react will with reactive
course picks up on the change in data
and since down here we're actually like
we're actually rendering these so I got
to throw it on these events so rendering
this this data in these events so if the
order of the state is if anything in
data changes then it reacts going to
rerender these so if we change the order
based on location and state react picks
up on the state change and then these
will automatically reorder and that's
exactly what we want to happen so
basically that is the last step in this
process is simply sorting by distance
before we set this and then at that
point when this gets set everything will
be render it will work so
[Music]
so patrick saying that you need in else
on location map that sets the distance
to event on others what i'm going to do
i think is either have the the person
who's in charge of content go in and set
the location for everything so i won't
have to worry about not having a
location in there or i'll just go and do
it myself and then i'm going to make
that a required field so every new event
added in it they have to put the
location on it i i don't think there's
going to be anything like online event
or anything where there wouldn't be a
location so i think i can get away
setting that is mandatory and then i
won't have to worry about it and that'll
save me the time from having to put that
in the code anyway
yeah Brandi says should always check for
no anyways can never depend on your
users and I thumbs up for that yeah if I
do although I was if I make it a
required field then they won't actually
even be able to make a new event unless
they set the field so if there were to
be an error it would be either like the
Google API stop working like maybe I hit
my limit on on that or something so
actually there could be there could be
an instance where maybe something
happens with the Google API messing up
so so I will do that in the add this
all right so Patrick's saying add
infinity what how do i how do I make
something infinity this is another one
as questions that I'm just like I
probably should know this
I'm sure this is one of those like
questions in JavaScript basics that I
just don't know because because I always
jumped around when learning things to
just learn whatever I needed for the
project that I was doing and I have gaps
in my education math infinity okay
cool thank you that makes sense and I
mean honestly I probably sorry I even
asked that I definitely could look that
up so oh you don't even need math so you
could so so I can just do infinity then
that's really cool
all right so yeah actually that's the
JIT check this out in the console so
infinity is infinity awesome
so sweet so that should work
cool that's cool I learned so many new
things new and useful things today so I
am going to make sure I commit this and
push it to the git repo because if I
need to or want to work on this on
vacation I'll definitely need it in the
repo because I can't take my iMac with
me alright so just wanna make sure it's
I I probably don't need to do this but I
always type gets that it's like almost
always just to make sure that I didn't
accidentally edit any other files
without realizing it so
and shiny what if it's been so long
we've been working on this I want to
make sure I remember what we did our
last commit was what was that we didn't
have Alaskan I do
okay get user location I thought we did
so we have get user location so now it's
going to be
[Music]
all right that works that pretty much
sums up what we did it's crazy that all
that work summed up in such a short
commit message but I still feel good
that we did it and by we I mean mostly
you and I did the typing whoa what
errors figures it figures I thought I
was done and now I have errors where's
my errors a regular whitespace seriously
a regular wage face well at least it
tells me exactly where so J is 56 so is
it because it's because of this what is
this wait where is my irregular
whitespace
does anybody know with the Hecate it's
still in me for a regular regular white
space alright let me see let me check
the live chat
you all don't have to watch me figure
out these areas that this is not like
major errors everything works it's just
I have some weird white space somewhere
that I have to find let me check really
quick in a chat I'm probably not going
to go through the whole chat this time
to answer questions for two reasons one
I'm just I'm really tired and I need to
just be done also like this stream has
been so long there probably aren't that
many people that have been here since
the beginning so they might not even be
around to hear the answer so I am going
to save this live chat and then read
through it later on and and try to
answer that maybe in the future in a
future live stream or put it in the
comments for this video or something
like that
alright so laundry has a quick question
which setting did you use in order to be
able to use the spread operator on
objects when I use it in chrome dev
tools it does not work um let's see okay
Patrick Patrick gave the answer that I
was going to give ya so all my all the
babble transpiling stuff that I'm doing
right now is building an XJS I haven't I
haven't done anything with that
so I'm not sure exactly what they have
going on I probably says in their
documentation so I'm assuming that they
are allowing you know their transpiling
pretty much you know the cutting edge
since I've never used anything that
hasn't worked in terms of newer
JavaScript stuff so whatever whatever
flavor of Babel
all they're using is covers most most
things at least everything I've tried
let's see
okay I copy and pasted okay sha thank
you so much um so I copy everything I
can op even pasted this line from the
chat which I need to just quit that
because it keeps messing me up so maybe
maybe that'll solve it let's see
shoot it's happening again but actually
I didn't think about this before but it
is telling me it's lying
what is it line 56:42 am I
4000 man that's weird you guys see that
so I can click here this is really weird
so I I'm going to click three times and
watch what happens I click three times 1
2 3
between that 2nd and 3rd click it
doesn't move so that's definitely it and
hopefully this isn't okay looks like
that one works that is so weird
I've I've never seen that there we go
and that worked awesome
sweet okay so all everything we just did
is now up in the repo on github under
the geolocation branch so you can check
it out if you want to alright so thank
you to everyone this was insanely a long
stream and thanks everybody you stuck
around was just like a four-hour stream
I can't believe that so yeah I'm not
gonna talk a lot at the end of this one
thanks and I will see you all I'll be
back a week not next week but the week
after I should be back on Monday so yeah
thanks thanks everybody I really
appreciate have have a great day and
have it have a great weekend and next
week and then I'll see you later and
I'll be on Twitter and in the IRC room
and stuff like that so yeah any
questions or anything like that just you
know message me on twitter I'll be
around